it's just crazy to be here after eight
years so you know I'm excited that's
Lisa Vanderpump for sure 100% The Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills are back for
season eight what's your one word to
describe this season I would say glam
tastic CT was on the red carpet with the
cast for their premiere party in LA
where we had a little surprise for them
I have a question from a famous superfan
for you I love her so much I love her so
much I am a super fan right back okay
let me compose myself who's the new girl
and where's Eileen I want to know where
she is
has she been abducted and who's the new
girl I don't know anything about her and
I think that's not fair given that I'm a
dedicated devoted viewer and I would
like to have some more information at
the start you know she deserves up okay
she deserves it Miss Sarah paulsen I
have an answer for you Eileen Davidson
is unfortunately not with us this season
I miss her incredibly Eileen has not
been abducted by aliens she's very busy
doing two different stuff hoppers same
time I could say I'm not the new girl
anymore so that's kind of fun girl
anymore so who is the new girl
new girl Teddy Mellencamp teddy Joe
Mellencamp John Mellencamp's daughter
who is 36 who's a baby okay she's a baby
let's face it she's beautiful she's fun
she's down to earth she's honest yeah I
think you may like her young fresh
opinionated but you know you're gonna
like me better you are saying
I think Weesa Rena can be schizophrenic
Teddy's down-to-earth she cuts the chase
there's no [ __ ] and she does call
some people out and she's got a
different flavor and I think she's great
addition not everybody might agree with
me but Carl and I we we adopt her so she
gets our approval so done she's staying
I'm not gonna sugarcoat something I'm
never mean but I'm straightforward and
if you're trying to beat around the bush
it drives me nuts choosing an
accountability coach so we have to you
know the audience has to watch to see if
she keeps any of the women accountable
for their actions but I can say that no
matter how old you are I'll always hold
you accountable I don't need anyone to
keep me accountable I'm pretty good on
my own thing
you
[Music]